jaspers main lebt hallo ich meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen wertvorstellung und zwar von der
graffiti motive wie der name schon sagt
ein paar sachen bezüglich gravity hinzu
also bezüglich schwerkraft da hätten wir
zum beispiel so ein paar sachen wo
einfach alles um einen herum anfängt zu
schweben
da hätten wir auch noch ein blog der
einen weg drückt und alle anderen mops
oder ein run zieht oder das gleich in
verschiedene richtungen und alles
mögliche da gibt es richtig richtig
viele sachen und ich stelle euch jetzt
erst mal kurze kräftige sachen vor und
zwar als erstes den grammy tor
der sieht so aus den habe ich jetzt
gerade der hand er ist ein bisschen so
wie ein zebra crafted ihr euch so indem
wir hier für eisenwaren in die ecken
legt in die mitte ein kompass und allein
redstone dann gibt es auch noch einen
directional grammy tor der sieht so aus
ist quasi genau das gleiche nur an einer
seite dieses zebra hafte hier haben wir
das in allen seiten
hier haben wir das nur einer seite das
geht dann nur in eine richtung dieses
gravitations mäßige funktion des uns das
machen wir ganz einfach indem wir hier
oben das weglassen und den redstone auch
und einfach quasi beiden also um
weglassen haben wir noch das hier und da
haben wir einen directional reggaeton
und dann gibt es noch einen traktor
traktor sieht so aus selbst ein bisschen
rot und davon gibt es nun auch einen
directional traktor also hier der
traktor und da der directional attraktor
die sowie der traktor gekracht und so
der direction traktor sich und einfach
das redstone und die zwei eisen übrig
gelassen der traktor drückt einen an
sich ran also wenn man den aktiviert
dann zieht er ein an sich ran und dazu
sage ich gleich auch noch mal ein
bisschen dann gibt es auch den report
der sich so aus wie der traktoren blau
und davon gibt es auch diesen
directional rösler der dann nur in eine
richtung geht der wird so betrachtet
also relativ ähnlich wie der hier wieder
ein traktor los ein bisschen diese hier
so ein bisschen vertauscht und der
direction dörrie pulver wird die kräfte
die man das einfach unten weg lässt dann
gibt es noch die gravity boots die sehen
so aus und zwar wenn man diese an hat
dann bekommt man gar keine wirkung von
dem gravity sachen also man ist quasi
komplett
nicht schweren los aber man ist quasi
komplett immun gegen die ganze sache die
werden so gekracht die man sich erst bei
traktors macht und darüber einfach zwei
eisenwaren und jetzt kommen zu der
funktion von den ganzen sachen und zwar
brauchen wir für alles eine redstone
fackelt ich liebe zählt zum beispiel
eine traktor oder setzen wir einfach
jetzt in der mitte damit ihr dass sie
besser seht dann macht jetzt erstmal gar
nichts nicht so wird machte dicht wir
können allerdings nicht da drauf auch
nicht irgendwie dran oder so sondern
daneben dann fängt er an zu leuchten und
ihr seht schon ich werde an das teil
angezogen wenn ich versuche wegzulaufen
ich drücke gerade die ganzen wm will weg
und ich springe jetzt und ich fliege
auch gerade versuche zu fliegen und so
was alles ihr seht dass das mein
bildschirm wenn man so ein bisschen
auseinander geht dass ich versucht zu
fliehen
ich komm hier nicht weg ich werde die
komplett angezogen ich kann mir zwar so
ein bisschen rumlaufen aber ich werd
quasi komplett angezogen das geht erst
wenn diese redstone fackel aus machen
dann kann ich einfach weg gehen ich kann
jetzt ja auch alles dransetzen wenig
angezogen das wird quasi immer schneller
und das ganze funktioniert in zwölf
blöcke also wenn ich da als das ist
jetzt ein bisschen blöd mit dem dran
setzen so wenn ich etwas angezogen
können jetzt einen redstone nur bauen
hier so irgendwie bleibens da hinten hin
bis 12 lag oder so ein schalter daran
setzt dann werde ich immer noch
angezogen
allerdings wird das dann erst so ganz
langsam sein so und dann wird's immer
schneller und damit irgendwann so
nämlich direkt daran also sieht das ja
schon bin ich quasi hier so der ecke
steht eine fackel ansätze ich drücke ich
werde einfach angezogen bin dann immer
näher daran so das ist der traktor davon
gibt es auch einen der action tracker
und zwar kann ich den so hinsetzen oder
irgendwie so oder so
oder 8 momente oder auch so in die höhe
das ziemlich auch ganz witzig und zwar
wenn ich dann quasi hier fliege und ich
setze ich eine fackel hin werde ich von
oben angezogen wenn ich allerdings setze
ich pack diana weg hier ein hab ich kann
einerseits von hier aktivieren oder von
da oder von hier
das ist relativ egal ihr seht schon
diese sachen sind so ein bisschen so wie
obsidian solms sieht jahren so ein
bisschen wie bottrop meine ich wenn ich
da bin ist das alles vollkommen egal
wenn ich allerdings hierhin laufe werde
ich von ihr angezogen ich allerdings
hier wieder bin ist das nicht da also
das ist quasi ganz cool wenn man
beispielsweise einem ob alle bauen will
und oben werden mops generiert also die
irgendwie hat man loks bonner und
anstatt wasser kann man dann einfach
diese impulse beispielsweise nehmen die
dann wegdrücken dann macht man einfach
ganz federico soll so dann hat man
beispielsweise hier oben die spanner und
die ganze nacht feiern hier hin und
werden dann von hier weg gedrückt und
dann werden die weiter gericht und hier
kann man die daneben töten weil wenn man
dagegen läuft dann ihr seht schon ich
kann das war so ein bisschen gegen
laufen aber weiter als hier kann ich
nicht also ich laufe gerade geradeaus
ich kann da nicht weiter dran also es
gibt einmal so ein limit ich kann es ich
kann hier direkt vor laufen auch wenn
ich irgendwie okay wenn ich fliege bin
ich wieder da drüber aber so ich kann
die quasi so richtig in laufe ich werde
immer so ein bisschen weggedrückt also
das ist quasi der repulse der directory
pulver und das leicht gibt es dann quasi
auch noch mal in diesem normalen mit
pulse also wenn ich jetzt drauf drücken
werde ich hier überall weggedrückt zeigt
auch noch mal wenn ich da drauf stehe
werde ich konnte nach oben gedrückt
werden je weiter weg gedrückt bleiben
aber bereits seht ihr das auch mit
diesen zwölf blöcken dass das quasi
weiter wirkt weil ich werde immer noch
weiter von der plattform web weggedrückt
hier bin ich jetzt weg
also außerdem zwölf blöcke radius raus
ihr seht da schon auch hier bin ich
immer noch um diesen zwölf blöcke radius
ich werde immer weiter weggedrückt ich
mach nix hier ich werde bis hierhin
weggedrückt und das ganze ist dann quasi
seit zwölf blöcke radios und ich
versuche jetzt mal irgendwie die
redstone fackel da irgendwie weg zu
kriegen so und das gleiche habe ich euch
ja schon gezeigt in denen directory
pulver variante dann grammy topfit ich
am coolsten funktioniert auch nicht so
wenn ich hier nichts machen sondern muss
sich auch bauern und ich flieg einfach
hoch ihr seht es ist noch nichts auch
wenn ich jetzt mal ein game mode 0 gesät
ich fliege weiter hoch allerdings hat
das jetzt glaube ich seine grenze
erreicht jetzt gleich sind wir ja genau
jetzt mir bei der ganze höher geht es
nicht es ist halt auch nur zwölf blöcke
radius nur zwei blöcke weil sonst würde
ich ja quasi mal weiter raus fliegen
wenn ich jetzt allerdings man die
gravity schuhe anziehen völlig runter
und krieg als schaden also die schuhe
geben also ein bisschen protection ihr
seht das so ca ich weiß nicht wie viel
ist das so wie eisen oder sowie gold ich
glaub sowie gold und leder
also ich gebe nicht so viel protection
hier unten aber damit ist man quasi
komplett wirkungslos wenn ich jetzt
wieder ausziehen bin ich wieder der luft
wenn ich jetzt wieder anziehe bin ich
wieder hier
wie genau das gleiche ist auch mit
pulver und dem teil so wenn ich dir
jetzt quasi alle an passiert gar nichts
wenn ich jetzt allerdings ausziehen
werde ich gerade weggedrückt also die
wirkung überschlägt es nicht mehr
game 1 und ziehen wir die die schule
habe ich wäre das perfekt also wenn ich
quasi hier drauf bin und ich will jetzt
meine schuhe ausziehen dann würde ich
einerseits hiervon abgestoßen werden
ich würde dann außerdem auch noch in die
luft gestoßen werden von diesem teil und
hiervon wieder angezogen werden deswegen
werde ich quasi hier dann oder werde ich
quasi hier wieder angezogen allerdings
blockieren sich die beiden und ich will
dann irgendwie in der luft schweben oder
irgendwie sowas also das ist ganz cool
was man damit alles für experimente
machen kann
besonders bezogen auffallen oder auch
den multiplayer ab und da ist begonnen
auch einfach mal minecraft mal eben
abgestürzt das ist irgendwie
vollbildmodus gegangen und dann
abgestürzt also keine ahnung warum tut
es leid dass jetzt ein blöder katrin ist
allerdings soll es uns dass hier gar
nicht stören und zwar habe ich hier
schon so einen kleinen bereich aufgebaut
habe auch schon ein paar mal hier in der
hand gegeben dafür meist das ganze hier
auf einfach und macht die time
vielleicht einfach mal auf neu das sieht
dann glaube ich ein bisschen cooler aus
ich glaube ist ja gar nicht gut aus
welche gar kein licht drin habe aber das
ist doch relativ egal so ich spannend
sie erstmal fahren mops und zwar jede
spinne in schweinen fährten scharf
dorfbewohner und truhen und dann nehme
ich mir jetzt immer einen rap song
fackeln und ihr wollt ihr alle sehen was
passiert der männer hat ganz nah mit mob
stattfindet nicht als allererstes nicht
mal ganz kurz diesen traktor die ganze
sache dran zieht ich habe gravity bhutan
also ob für mich wirkt das ganze nicht
wie ihr seht schon zeigt und allem ob
sind da dran und wenn ich das weg machte
dann kriegen die sogar alle ein bisschen
schade weil jeder wieder zurück gedrückt
werden
allerdings ist das ganze echt extrem da
muss die fakten hin hallo und garten das
echt witzig mal die ganzen mops fielen
stark aus kriegen alles ein bisschen
schaden jetzt mal das ganze pulver das
nämlich auch ganz witzig und zwar wären
jetzt einfach alle weggedrückt und alle
sind irgendwie nicht so ganz spektakulär
das muss man machen wenn der raum
bisschen größer ist so und jetzt sind
alle wieder da jetzt kommen alle wieder
cool ist das ganze wenn man das erst mit
dem reporter macht
und jetzt geht alles wieder weg und auch
ganz cool ist es ganz mit gravity und
zwar setzt jetzt einfach die brocken und
jetzt fangen alle an zu schweben
jacobi macht das ganze hier oben jetzt
mal kaputt mal schauen dann schweben sie
gleich alle hier irgendwie durch die
luft ich schlage ihnen die ganze zeit
diese spinne ihr die totale alt fliegt
meine freunde freaks die sympathischen
oben krass so kann man das ist also man
kann extreme witzige sachen damit den
mops machen vor allem auffallen da will
auch hochwahrscheinlich com online
lernen fliegen
wir können damit echt richtig richtig
coole sachen machen vor allem ich das
ganze wieder ausmache sei für alle tot
also dass das hühnchen dass das fliegt
das auf droht ab aber jetzt fliegt
wieder hoch und gefährlichen auch und
ich ziehe jetzt aber die schuhe aus und
fliegt mit euch und damit würde ich
sagen was dieser mann verstand man kann
super coole sachen damit machen
besonders bezogen auf irgendwelche kopf
fallen oder so stell ich mir das extrem
witzig vor auch ein multiplayer extrem
geil und ich kann dir gar nicht wieder
richtig runter weil die zeit gravity
also ich habe das echt extrem cool von
amerikanern richtig richtig coole sachen
machen glaube ich wenn es euch gefallen
hat und eventuell weitere mod videos
wollt dann lasst einfach einen daumen
hoch da damit sehe ich das schaffen wir
2008 das wäre auf jeden fall ein cooler
meilenstein und natürlich sagen
tschüss und wir sehen uns beim ist mal
wieder